hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the fide grand prix
2022. it's hikaru nakamura vs alexander
garishuk and it's uh well just a very
nice king's indian defense game with
sasha playing the king's indian and he
carplaying against the king's indian
which is very enjoyable we all know how
strong hikaru is in the king's indian
but this is classical let's see what
happens so hikaru uh with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 uh c for g6 knight to c3 and bishop
to g7 the king's indian defense is on
the board uh we have e4 uh the
normal stuff here we have d6 bishop to
e2 and uh grisha castles and here hikaru
plays bishop to e3
this is the so-called averbach system
maybe paying a tribute to the to the old
grand master who just turned 100 but
also maybe it's just his favorite line
so maybe it has nothing to do with that
so here we have e5 standard reply asking
why are you maybe interested in a nice
queen trade and the white of course
grabs more space with d5 now we have
knight to a6 by grishok and now hikaru
just strikes with h4 uh interestingly g4
here is a far more played than h4 even
though h4 kind of makes more sense you
want to push that pawn to h5 but you
will at some point play g4 as well so
and maybe it's uh you know a little bit
of both but hikaru prefers a h4 and now
just knight to c5 we are going after the
e4 pawn so hikaru has to waste the move
defending it we have queen to c2 and now
c6 uh attacking hikaru strong center and
hikaru ignores this he continues
attacking with h5 we have cd5 uh c
captures on d5 and now queen to a5
saying that uh okay you you really have
nothing here uh i'm pinning your knight
so everything uh
you know could just explode if you allow
me this capture on e4 but he car plays
h6 attacks the bishop here on g7 bishop
to h8 and now he wastes one move again
uh defending the position with f3 and
now you can see that his pawn
is all the way to h6 he has a very
strong center here his king is still in
the center of the board so uh you know
really really uh exciting stuff
happening here
bishop to d7 and now rook to b1 here
hikaru is preparing b4 to win material
here
and knight to a for now attacking the
pinned piece we have queen to d2 and now
knight captures on c3 he carol captures
with the b pawn with b captures on c3
now the b7 pawn is hanging and uh
grishok defends it with queen to c7 and
up until this point this is known
territory there is even a game from 2019
bundesliga between pablo ellianov and um
adam chenko
where the
uh game continued with c4 and that game
ended in a draw but here we have
g4 by hikaru and it is now as of move 17
that we have a completely new game and
um
okay g4 seems very aggressive but it's
not like you can continue attacking g5
the knight moves and that's it you don't
have any any more pawns to push so how
will this continue well bishop to c8
first uh adding a defender here so now
the queen can move but maybe also you're
play planning to play b6 so knights the
h3 by hikaru knights to d7 and now
knight to f to bring the knight to d3 we
have knight to f6 uh sorry not knight
bishop to f6 and maybe uh trying to get
hikaru to push that phone all the way to
g5 but hikaru just castles here so it
seemed like he car was attacking the
king side all along but now he castles
king's side and well what will happen
now the center is pretty much closed uh
unless we see something like c4c5 here
it's uh uh you know about to remain by
about to remain closed and uh will the
game shift to the queen side or will
there be some sort of a breakthrough on
the king side so here we have bishop
back to e7 king to h2 by hikaru and now
knight to c5
we have knights to d3 offering a trade
of knights and just b6 strengthening the
knight here but hikaru trades on c5
knight captures b captures and now uh he
plays f4 and now interestingly even
though hikaru also castles on the king
side there doesn't seem to be a good way
to prevent uh
white from advancing those pawns of
course uh aggressive captures on f4 we
have bishop captures and bishop back to
d7 uh again connecting the rooks but now
c4 and here
we have rook 8 to b8 and the rook 8 to
b8 just claiming the b file for your own
rook
countering white's rook on b1 is very
impressive
but
agriculture
really doesn't mind if hikaru just puts
the queen on c3 so maybe instead bishop
to f6 is a little bit safer uh but uh
sasha of course knows what he's doing
and he's uh it's only moved 26 i believe
he's now
below 10 minutes probably i know he was
extremely low on the clock here because
he car played like the first 15 moves
with um uh
more than an hour and a half on the
clock so he had a positive time uh
whereas grayshock spent more than an
hour so oh as usual sasha do is doing
his thing uh we have queen to c3 he car
of course says all right i'm threatening
checkmate and uh of course f6 we are
preventing this rook to be three saying
okay i'm gonna play rook to b1 double up
here and if you capture i'm going to
connect my pawn structure here so rook
to b6 sasha considering the same and now
we have g5 and now you can see that it's
impossible to
stop those phones from breaking through
because uh well if you captured queen g7
is just checkmate so here
we have rook to f7 now you are
well just welcome to capture because the
rook is guarding the g7 square and now
bishop the c1 not only adding more
pressure to the f6 square but we are
shifting this bishop over to b2 and then
the bishop and queen will also have
access to the h8 square so queen d8 now
comes the bishop to b2 of course that's
what we were planning queen to f8
and now king to g2 before opening up the
position uh we get our king to a little
bit of a safer square also adding
another defender to the rook here if the
position opens up so bishop to d8
and now comes queen to f3 uh so what can
you play here uh well the problem with f
captures on g5 even though it seems like
such a nice move because now you're also
attacking the queen this is probably
what hikar was planning is queen back to
c3 and this is very annoying uh and now
if you play rook captures on f1 we can
play queen to h8 with check if king to
f7 queen captures an h7 with check king
e8 queen captures on g6 with check and
finally after queen f7 we can easily
trade here captures captures and now
just rook captures and b6 h captures and
bishop to h5 and now the rook cannot
move and h7 h8 will just win the game if
you unpin we're gonna capture the rook
and the h7 wins the game as the bishop
covers the uh h8 square bishop here of
course we just trade and bring the queen
into the game so that's the idea after
queen to c3 if you just play rook
captures on f1 but if you play bishop to
f6 then we just win the piece because
well black simply does not have enough
defenders so that's why you can't open
up the position just yet so here bishop
the c8 a very important uh defending
move
by grishok because he knows
the position will open up and that this
king will have to go for a nice walk and
you do not want your king stuck here you
want to
have the d7 square free for your king so
that's the idea uh and uh also maybe if
this rook moves he has some plans of
maybe bringing this rook over to help
out with the seventh rank but i think
it's mostly just uh
you know uh
allowing the king to escape so now queen
to e3 getting the queen away from the
f-file and now comes rook captures on
eight captures and finally f captures on
g5 it seems like uh you really shouldn't
do this but now sasha says that it's
okay to walk the plank here so queen to
c3 uh going for that queen to h8
checkmate uh he captures on f1 uh queen
to h8 would check now the the difference
is um
from that line that we've shown the
bishop is on c8 not on d7 so the king
can cross this uh but also it's just
very interesting because after king f7
queen captures an h7 check kink the e8
queen to g6 check kink the e7
uh not uh king to d7 right away because
then just bishop captures on f1 and it's
uh well just very silly so instead kink
the e7 was played but now comes queen
captures and g1 uh the idea is that if
if you capture for example the bishop
bishop captures on f1 there's this very
nasty bishop to h3 check
sasha is just full of tricks here king
captures queen captures on f1 and now no
longer hikaru has anything but hikaru so
through right through this he plays
queen captures on g5 with check uh and
now uh it seems like king the d7 is what
you want to play but even this will not
help gurishu because if king d7 there's
this bishop g4 check king c7 queen to g7
check and now there's really nothing uh
nothing left if king b8 we're gonna
capture here after rook captures just
bishop captures on c8 and that's it king
captures h7 and again uh you are just
bringing a queen into the game
uh no stopping this if you play bishop
here we just capture or still guard the
h8 square it doesn't matter if rook here
queen comes into the game with check
picks up the rook so that that will not
work so instead after queen to g5 check
rook to f6 was played but now again uh
the position is completely winning for
hikaru uh we've reached move 40 so time
control has been reached both players
now have sufficient time on the clock
but there is one move that wins the game
and only one move so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for hikaru
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is kinked no
i'm just kidding of course it is pawn to
h7 that's the winning move and uh well
now there's simply
not much you can do here uh the queen
can't really move uh if you try
something like queen to h8 we can just
capture here after queen captures the
bishop captures uh the h8 square will
always be uh ready for our uh for our
pawn to become a queen so here uh grisha
finally played king to d7 but now hikaru
just played queen to g8 uh as again this
is the only winning move and he was in
this position on uh mu 42 that alexander
grishok resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
really impressive game by hikaru so far
in the tournament uh it's still unknown
who will win this uh
uh this uh group as he has the same
amount of point points as this pencil
and tomorrow he's playing especially
spank will have the white pc car will
have black so we'll see uh how that uh
turns out but should be should be very
interesting so here there's really
nothing after rook to have to check you
have this one check and that's it no
more moves for black whatever you do
well we can just play h8 queen or
capture the queen then h8 queen
everything is winning uh so of course uh
grishok resigned uh that's the game
another very impressive victory by
hikaru who not only plays a great king's
indian but also as you've seen
plays great against the king's indian
defense uh so yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed it once again i would like to
thank the hoodie knight god for making
me an atheist john anderson uh sorry
about that uh in this position feel free
to pause the video and jonathan kemp for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video grand prix until
it ends so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day